it's a moment Moscow has been waiting
foreign
the capture of solidar became possible
thanks to the continuous strikes on the
positions of the Armed Forces of Ukraine
by Russian Air Force missiles and
artillery
Moscow hopes solidar will be a stepping
stone to another strategic Ukrainian
City
I think that only after the liberation
of bakmut will an offensive operation be
prepared to help complete the liberation
of Donetsk from Ukraine solidar opens
the way for Russian military units to
crumb a torsk this is the largest city
of the Donetsk People's Republic still
held by Ukrainian nationalists but
there's another battle going on this one
inside the Russian establishment over
the Royal mercenaries from the Wagner
group played in capturing solidar the
group posted on its telegram Channel a
statement in the form of an answered
question accusing some officials of
trying to steal its Victory while
stressing that the only Fighters present
in the battle for solidar were Wagner
Fighters
the ministry of Defense later issued a
statement confirming that Wagner's role
was essential in the battle for solidar
Wagner is not registered in Russia we do
not have a law on private military
companies therefore apparently the
military is trying not to mention Wagner
as part of the group that performs the
tasks of the special military operation
of course this is very insulting to the
Wagner Fighters and the case is also
about the jealousy of some generals
which are more cities The Echoes of the
battle in Moscow for the heart and mind
of Vladimir Putin may be heard in the
battlefields in Ukraine Moscow